Hey, Bill, how are you?
Hey, Shashank, I am good. How are you?
I'm good too. How's everything going on your end?
Yes.
Everything is perfectly fine. What about yourself?
All going good. Everything is in place. Things are moving in the right direction. Last one I got an update from Venkat, like she's performing well, so.
Nine.
I am very.
Happy that she is, and we are on the right track. That's there, so I'll just give it just a what we do on these calls, so it's like kind of a monthly review that we do. Usually we do it with the SDMs and the details, like Venkata has Venkat has some.
Okay.
other things to take care so you can also give your inputs. We equally value the inputs both from TTL as well as the SDM. And so, and this is a monthly recurring call, so we'll meet month by month. Otherwise, if you see or find any issue or if you need.
any of my help with Kumar, you can ping me and I can work along with that.
With common, I think this is the first one.
OK.
Yes, this is the first group.
Comma.
So I have prepared a small presentation. So we'll go over that. And this is a fixed format that we follow with F12. So we have specific things in place. So the agenda is like check-in highlights, action tracker, KPI analysis, end user CSAT analysis.
No.
Mhm.
Okay.
Yes.
way forward and upcoming events and then the recap.
So highlights like Komal is doing good. So just being in the system for a month, her metrics are looking very good. Overall we can see a good progress over there. She has been adapting well and I specifically asked all my engineers and asked her.
Like are you liking the work and everything? So she is really liking the work and she feels very supportive with you and Venkat. She said like I get all the help whenever I need it. So thank you so much for that. Thank you for making her so only feel that I would say.
Kip.
No, no, it's like she's a part of our team, and you know it's our responsibility to behave like that, so we...
Keep supporting each and every technician, like it is for my ITBD or it is for me and how it is equal for us, so that is the way we we used to work.
Yeah, and that's the culture I have seen with F12, with other techs as well. There is no differentiation that happens. I totally agree with you. I haven't seen any discrimination happening with any of the engineers.
All right, it will not be like this. For us, every technician is equal same, even as you mentioned the feedback and suggestion to work. Komal is working very well in the initial phase. She, as she's a tier one, low-hanging issues she's fixing like that.
Yes, there is some like concern, some escalations, please, for, but you know, there is a part of onboarding, she missed some documentation, she missed something, but that is where I'm working with.
an escalation from...
Even yesterday, there was an escalation from Ben. She missed a couple of things in onboarding. But again, as I said, this is a part of onboarding as in IST. So I will not say this is a complaint from my side. It is something that we have a big hope from Komal and we are working closely with Komal to make sure that she
Yeah.
She will not do this mistake again and again, and she will be, you know, like somebody who has experienced. So, for now, we are good and hoping good in future as well. As you said, this will be a monthly, sorry to interrupt you. As you said, this will be a monthly call, so I will say that within a month I will be...
Yep.
Yeah, and...
I will be in good condition to give more feedback about this because right now it's a learning phase for Kumar.
Yeah, and I totally agree with you. The onboarding process is very complex because when there was an access team, I know how complex it was because few of the engineers were relying from our end as well. So I know it's not an easy process or an easy job that I would say. It's kind of a difficult thing to persist onboarding. There are a lot of checks that we need to do.
Mhm.
lot of automations that we need to follow and then there are manual checks. So definitely this is a very critical task and I know misses happen, but she's learning. Now when you give feedbacks to her, do you see that challenge?
Happening or issues reoccurring with her?
That is what I am saying that I am not in condition to say that issue is reoccurring for now because we got escalations, two, three escalations in just three, four days before that it was okay. So, but whatever we are saying, she's learning, she's not doing it again. That's what I'm saying that after one month, I will be in better position to tell you that.
Oh.
I got you.
Issues are reoccurring or not.
Yeah, got it. Understand your point. That's completely valid. Moving on to-dos, there was no to-dos. Performance analysis and utilization is at 59% for first month. This is good. I do not expect her to reach 80% in the first month because again, she would be learning, she would be reading some documents.
That's where her time goes, so 80% is a bar for.
For us, for us, for us, is good, like targeting 7 hour a day, and she's okay for dial pad, like she handling dial pad very well, except really good for her, because we need somebody who can manage dial pad, so she's managing dial pad well, so from installation point of view, I think we are good.
I'm not sure how you're mailing it, but we are good.
Yeah, so what I do and I'll like to show it to you. Just a moment. So this is a bright gauge that we have and in that we I get the details of all the engineers. So this is for daily thing that I see and then there are ticket closed by ITBD techs.
Mhm.
Good.
Yeah.
It's for 90 days in parallel. And then we have time entered last seven days. So I calculate utilization on time entered on daily basis.
Mhm.
I can do it.
Okay.
Vince.
From there, I'm calculating the utilization, and when I say 80%, it should be 80% of seminars that I'm calculating, so that's what I'm calculating, that that's a main bar that they need to reach.
No.
Okay.
But that will increase now, anyhow, because month of month of June, July, and August is month of onboarding off boarding.
Yeah, I know.
The more tickets she will enter, the more time she will consume on that.
I know, I totally agree with that. And I've seen the trends like none of the engineers reached that bar in the first two months. So I know it would take around one or two months. Ticket closures, that's good. 110, that's for the first one, that's a really good number. So that's great. CSAT.
Phelps.
Cut.
Yeah.
It's 100% over 9 surveys. Good. I know the target is 15 for every engineer in F2, but yes, I know she will reach after some time.
The.
A good idea for him.
No, thank you.
But in first month, first month, 9 is OK.
I would say 9 is good.
Again, because...
Yeah, 9 is good. Nine is good because she's handling enforcement. I have not given her any complex issues. So she's handling tier one to calls like where she has to work on backend only. She's not working on front end. So even working on backend, 9 is good, I would say.
Yeah.
Moving on next, this is an attendance piece which we manage and we show all the details like all the holidays which she has taken, all the holidays which she has been given, what are the planned and unplanned leaves, all those things. And I know like 18th is a holiday in F12.
No.
So that's upcoming. So one day she took leave, that was 9th April. She was not well. So that's, and we will, we keep an update on this. We keep updating all our trackers on daily basis. So anytime she takes leave or anything, this will update.
Evan.
Bye.
Yeah.
Absolutely fine. Absolutely fine. So if you and somebody, even if Komal or you or of anybody can just inform me or Venkata that Komal is not available, that that is good for us. We can make the show.
Yeah. Way forward, I'll make sure that I work with Kumar if anything is required and make sure I'll keep motivating her. I'll keep guiding her so that she can follow the best practices and she does not get these escalations. I know this is primarily time. Things can happen, but yes.
The.
the experience for the F12 customer should not be debated.
Yeah.
Yeah, but Shashank, I just want to highlight one thing. She mentioned multiple times the connectivity issue that she's like the RDP is slow. She's not able to listen how the call is going on.
Is there any connectivity issue or like...
I guess I will talk to her in this case because she did not inform me specifically. Yeah, sometimes we have seen like RDS going slow and that is something that we escalate to Omega immediately. But if she is facing that regular, I'll get her laptop checked because.
No.
Yes.
Because.
No, good, good, completed.
Yeah, because I got one of the engineers who was facing similar problems while others were not. It was more of a laptop issue. I don't know how the laptop issue was making, but it was utilizing CPU A lot. Then we got the laptop change for that engineer and the issue resolved.
Mhm.
talk to her today itself and I'll see if there is some issue because for F12 specifically, we have a dedicated VLAN that we have created in an environment and all the engineers are on that VLAN. So the seat that she is sitting on, that is under F12 VLAN, so she should not.
face any issue. Plus we from our end we have given a 50 Mbps speed bandwidth to each and every engineer. And since that VLAN is dedicated for F12 only, so there should not be any concerns but I will talk to her and I'll get this sorted with her.
Thank you.
Okay.
Might be a reputation.
Because couple of, because couple of times I ask her, like, whenever she's facing some issue with the users, she can loop in by tier 2 or or somebody you know who is experienced with these two, and they told me that when they jump on their PC, their RDP is slow and she's not able to connect, and then Komal herself told me that.
Sometimes the calls are getting delayed or sometimes is RTV, so so.
Yeah, I'll, I'll...
So, like, it might be there, actually.
Yeah, I'll definitely look into this issue and get this sorted because it can be a laptop issue as well. However, the network bandwidth is not an issue. That I know because all of our engineers are working for FTL and they are not facing this issue. Sometimes it happens, but it's not. When I say sometimes it might happen once or twice in a month, not.
Sunidhi.
More than that.
Okay.
Okay, so that was the last part of the deck. Natalie is here. Natalie is a CX team and Natalie Iqbal is the TTL for Komal in ISG Nexus. Venkat was busy so he could not join and he said like...
Ohh.
Thank you.
Either me or Iqbal would join the call and we'll take that forward.
In Italy.
Thanks for the update. Nice to meet you. Yeah, I know, just getting started here. So we'll just see how it plays out. Any support that you need, Shashank is definitely there. And yeah, we definitely want to fix the connectivity. We don't like to have IT support with connectivity issues. Never a good.
Thank you.
In.
Audi's Kings, Fusions, whether saddens, mr.
But, for authentication, you need to enter.
Good luck.
To connect to the, sure, sure, Natalie. Thank you.
OK, and the thing you would like to add, Iqbal?
Nothing much like, as I said, that this was the first month and I will see Komal is learning with us. And Komal is doing good apart from this escalation, which me and Venkat is handling the other side. But next month, I think we will be in good shape and we will be
have some feedback for Kumar and I hope she will do good. And apart from that, everything is fine, like nothing specific.
Oh, great. Great to hear that. Thanks for the feedback, Iqbal, and thanks for being so honest and transparent. We really appreciate it.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thanks, Agarwal. Thanks, Natalie. Have a great day.
Thank you. Bye.
Bye.